regreso en gran pompa del tradicional
desfile militar del 14 de julio
presidido por emanuel juan manuel con
quien descendió en los campos elíseos a
bordo de un comando para saludar a las
miles de personas que pudieron este año
venir a disfrutar de este evento la
patrulla de francia fue la encargada de
pintar a los cielos de la capital con la
bandera de francia es uno de los
momentos que más a él le gustan a las
personas cerca de 5.000 militares se
desfilaron son varios de los regimientos
además de las escuelas de oficiales la
caballería y bueno había dos invitados
especiales en este desfile de hoy por
una parte los oficiales de la fuerza
tacuba son militares europeos que
participan en las labores de contra la
contra el terrorismo en el sahel en esas
regiones de áfrica y por otra parte muy
especial los o policías municipales de
niza justamente para rendirles un
homenaje a estos agentes cuando hoy se
están cumpliendo 5
de los atentados terroristas de niza
nada opacó este desfile a pesar de que
hubo un poco de lluvia un desfile que
también es muy musical en el que estuvo
presente el gobierno y la alcaldesa de
parís a anna hidalgo por supuesto estas
festividades que cierran con un gran el
concierto en la torre eiffel y fuegos
artificiales que este año tendrá en el
tema de la libertad